from my perspective just because just
working in an ai
i'm looking at the long term vision i i
see us
humans and ai systems as as really the
same
and ai systems ultimately as something
that
supersedes humans so what is
intelligence
so in the context of our current
discussion
i think intelligence is very closely
linked
to this notion of ideas
it's the ability to generate ideas
to mold ideas to
compress seeming chaos into some
model into some theory that uh
efficiently
compresses the chaos and in a way where
you can then integrate it with
other ideas and they can play and all
those kinds of things
so in that sense it's the turning chaos
into order
it's the molding of ideas such that our
human brains
can work with it and it just from my
perspective i don't see any reason why
they cannot be algorithmized
converted into compute computational
systems i would agree
um which is scary scary
or potentially really promising right
it's kind of the case with all novelty
it's terrifying
as much as it is promising that's why
you're pursuing it so heavily
i would maybe take it a step further and
say that intelligence
and maybe its most simplistic form is
error correction
so we
humans have wants again we're constantly
expressing our value
through action there's no other way to
express it by the way it's whatever you
choose to do in any moment
you are expressing the values you hold
in your mind and your heart
as we move from a from less valued a
to more valued b uh when we
entropy happens uncertainty happens we
we fall off course
and it is intelligence that enables us
to render information from that
experience and error correct
right so that we can move we can move
slightly change shift our trajectory
slightly
more towards uh b that we're trying to
move towards
so i think that
there's something there that i don't
know that we can
make synthetically and that when we if
we
if we define intelligence as error
correction it's like error correction to
what
error correction towards what we find is
valuable right
so we're trying to satisfy human wants
might not just be our own could be
others as well if i'm an entrepreneur
i'm trying to solve the wants of others
not just myself
and i'm trying to error correct myself
towards that goal
um using intelligence and processing
environmental feedback through
intelligence to error correct
so i don't know how if you eliminate
the human element completely who's doing
the wanting
right where does value come from i know
machine learning people who are
listening
are saying that's exactly what machine
learning is which is error correction
because you have a loss function
objective function
that measures how wrong your
thing is and you want to make it less
wrong next time that's the whole process
of machine learning
but you're saying what humans are able
to do
is in a world where there's there's no
maybe objective values absolute
values you're generating that very lost
function that objective function
that you're that function that measures
the error
comes from the human mind
uh some aliens might disagree with you
because they might have a different
objective function
purpose comes from consciousness i think
and without purpose there's not error
correction
yeah i mean this is again a hypothesis
like where does purpose come from
it seems to come from consciousness
you're right
that's where suffering comes from and
you want to lessen suffering
that's where pleasure comes from it
seems like it's consciousness
maybe there's something to this
biological meat bag
you